in the 1940s a cargo ship likely brought
a stow away to guam
the brown tree snake
since its arrival the snake's population
has exploded and eliminated almost all
native bird species on the island
that's had a domino effect on the
ecosystem
many tree species relied on birds
consuming their fruits and nuts to
disperse their seeds
this problem exceeds the small island of
guam widespread losses of birds and
mammals throughout the world have put
this crucial ecosystem service at risk
u.s and danish researchers set out to
measure how these declines impact plants
that rely on animals to move especially
as the climate changes
first they had to create models that
could predict two interactions between
plants and fruit eating animals
germination and how far seeds were
dispersed
previous models estimated how far an
animal can circulate a seed using a
simple relationship the larger the
animal the further it can transport a
seed
but there's more nuance to these
interactions
take two birds of a similar mass
one might travel far distances high
above the forest canopy while the other
fly shorter distances below the canopy
leading to different dispersal lengths
the researchers trained a model using
data from thousands of plant animal
interactions
this helped predict germination benefits
and dispersal distance for any pair of
animals and plants based on their traits
the scientists also modeled how plants
and animals might interact with each
other as they expand to new areas
most data on plant animal interactions
are between species that have shared the
same habitats for hundreds of thousands
if not millions of years
but climate change is shifting these
ranges causing species that never evolve
together to occupy the same space
using data from native species
researchers sought to predict the
closest stand-in for these future groups
species introduced to new areas by
humans
they found that species without a shared
history still interact with each other
if they share similar traits to native
species
next they used these models to estimate
how human activity has impacted the
ability for mammals to disperse seeds
long distances they found that most
regions of the world lack mammals or
birds that can transport seeds long
ranges
under a different scenario without
human-caused extinctions or species
introductions most regions of the world
would have animals that can transport
seeds far greater
the scientists then estimated how
species losses have changed the ability
for animal dispersed plants to keep pace
with climate change they found that on
average animal dispersed plants
experienced a 60 reduction in the
ability for their seeds to move to new
more suitable environments
the largest declines were in temperate
regions where large mammals that are
strong seed dispersers have disappeared
some large fruit eaters such as
elephants still exist in other parts of
the world maintaining these species are
crucial
in addition to conservation
re-establishing seed disbursers can help
strengthen resilience to climate change
from 2010 to 2017 conservationists in
brazil reintroduced the red rump to
goody and the brown howler monkey to the
chihuka national park
building wildlife corridors and
fragmented habitats could also make it
easier for animals to disperse seeds
more widely the researchers hope their
study will inspire others to evaluate
the ripple effect that species losses
have on highly connected ecosystems
you